[Música]
[Aplausos]
Ucrania despidió el 2022 en medio de la
guerra iniciada por Rusia y que ha
causado la muerte de decenas de miles de
personas y el desplazamiento de casi 8
millones de ucranianos fuera de su país
hacemos un recorrido por los eventos más
significativos del conflicto
Perú vivió una nueva crisis política que
provocó la salida y detención del
presidente Pedro Castillo decenas de
personas han muerto en las protestas que
surgieron en rechazo la destitución del
exmandatario y a través de las cuales
los manifestantes exigen la celebración
de nuevas elecciones
un año de cambios para Twitter el
multimillonario y los Moss compró la red
social y desde que se puso al frente El
Magnate ha tomado una serie de
decisiones que le han acarreado una ola
de críticas después de unos meses dijo
que se apartaría como director de la
compañía en esta misión repasamos sus
medidas más polémicas
Hola Bienvenidos a una nueva emisión de
noticias en France 24 esta emisión
especial en esta oportunidad revisamos
las noticias que han marcado el 2022 Y
empezamos en Ucrania que cerró el año en
guerra un conflicto que empezó el 24 de
febrero y cuyo fin no se vislumbra en el
corto plazo miles de personas han muerto
y casi 8 millones se han visto obligadas
a huir de los combates a continuación un
resumen de los sucesos de estos últimos
meses en el informe de Samuel Salgado
se trata del peor conflicto bélico en
Europa desde el fin de la Segunda Guerra
Mundial empezó el 24 de febrero como una
operación militar especial que según
Moscú buscaba desgasificar a Ucrania y
derivó en una guerra de desgaste los
primeros ataques rusos dejaban ver que
se trataba de una invasión a gran escala
por tierra tanques cruzaban desde las
fronteras de velarus desde el mar de
azov ráfagas de misiles y ataques
anfibios y por el cielo bombardeos desde
la anexada Península de crimea hacia
Ucrania gerson una urbestratégica a
orillas del río nípro cayó en marzo
junto a grandes zonas de la vecina
región de saporilla donde se encuentra
la planta nuclear más grande de Europa
generando preocupaciones sobre un
eventual desastre radioactivo en mayo
cayó mariopol luego de intensas batallas
en la planta siderúrgica de asoftal ante
la imposibilidad de tomar kiev debido a
la resistencia ucraniana Putin reenfocó
su estrategia y en julio los combates y
la toma de lisie changs marcaban el
nuevo epicentro de la guerra lugans
la ayuda económica de occidente permitió
Ucrania defenderse de ataques aéreos e
inclinar la balanza a su favor en el
campo de batalla varias ciudades y
enclaves ocupados fueron reconquistados
incluidas zonas en las regiones de
gersón doniak y lugansk que junto a
saporilla fueron anexadas a Rusia por el
presidente Putin tras celebrar
referendos rechazados por la comunidad
internacional al paso de la reconquista
se descubrieron fosas comunes atribuidas
a las fuerzas rusas como ocurrió en
bucha e isium y por las que la ONU
concluyó que hubo crímenes de guerra en
Ucrania el impacto del conflicto también
se sentía fuera de las fronteras
ucranianas este país que es uno de los
mayores exportadores de grano en el
mundo vio su actividad detenida por el
conflicto lo que generaba preocupaciones
de una crisis alimentaria pero en julio
un acuerdo entre las partes permitió
reanudar la salida de cereales desde los
puertos del mar Negro de otro lado Rusia
redujo el suministro de gas a los países
de la Unión Europea en respuesta a las
sanciones que el bloque le impuso por su
invasión a Ucrania agravando la crisis
energética en el viejo continente y en
medio alta demanda de los europeos para
generar energía ante la llegada del
Invierno Mientras tanto en territorio
ucraniano quien acusa a Rusia de atacar
infraestructura eléctrica clave dejando
a la población a oscuras sin acceso a
calefacción ni agua potable la comunidad
internacional acusa a Putin de utilizar
las frías temperaturas como un arma de
guerra contra Ucrania cambiamos de tema
el pasado 19 de septiembre el mundo dio
el último adiós a uno de los personajes
más importantes de la historia moderna
la Reina Isabel II quien falleció el 8
de septiembre marcando el fin de toda
una era asumir el trono cuando tenía
sólo 25 años y durante las siete décadas
de su reinado atravesó diversos cambios
sociales y momentos clave en la historia
de la humanidad Como por ejemplo el
colapso de la unión soviética la caída
del muro de Berlín la guerra fría y el
brexit Reino Unido está hoy en manos de
su hijo el Rey Carlos III nuestra
corresponsal en Londres Luisa Pulido nos
Explica el legado de la fallecida
monarca
Isabel segunda tuvo un reinado de más de
70 años que le dieron el récord de la
monarca británica más longeva este caso
se caracterizó por dar estabilidad en
tiempos de crisis al Reino Unido por la
consolidación del Cómo West que integran
hoy 53 países que reemplazo al imperio
británico y su inmensa popularidad en
todos los años se considera que su
coronación en 1953 puso fin al periodo
de austeridad en el Reino Unido tras la
Segunda Guerra Mundial por el despacho
de Isabel segunda pasaron 15 primeros
ministros el primero de ellos fue el
Héroe de la Segunda Guerra Mundial
Winston Churchill y la última fue listas
a Quien nombró apenas dos días antes de
su muerte la estabilidad y la
neutralidad política fueron sus grandes
aliadas en el largo reinado de Isabel
segunda el único momento que puso a
tambalear el futuro de la monarquía fue
su negativa inicial de permitir un
funeral de estado a la princesa Diana de
gales Quien murió en 1997 tras un
accidente de tránsito en París y los
escándalos personales de su hijo Andrés
y de Los Duques de sasex Harry y Megan
fueron sus últimos dolores de cabeza
entre tanto la coronación del Rey Carlos
tercero se realizará el próximo seis de
mayo de 2023 se asegura que será una
ceremonia que esté acorde con la
realidad económica del país y que será
mucho más inclusiva y será el reflejo de
una sociedad muchísimo más moderna
la muerte de la reina Isabel segunda no
Era lo único que estremecía a los
británicos en 2022 Reino Unido vivió
también una agitación política durante
la cual tres personas ocuparon el cargo
de Primer Ministro en menos de dos meses
la ya empañada administración del
entonces Premier Boris Johnson colapsó
en julio después de una revuelta en su
gabinete decenas de parlamentarios
conservadores renunciaron a sus puestos
en el gobierno y retiraron su apoyo a
Johnson tras una serie de escándalos
como el denominado Party Gates sobre las
fiestas que el ex líder organizaba
incumpliendo las restricciones de
coronavirus y las denuncias de conducta
sexual inapropiada de Chris Pincher a
quien Johnson había nombrado jefe
adjunto del partido conservador
finalmente dejó el cargo el 6 de
septiembre luego de que el Easy stroess
ganara las elecciones del partido
conservador pero otros sólo duró unas
siete semanas en el cargo su caída
estuvo precipitada por una tormenta
financiera que desató sus propuestas
económicas finalmente el 25 de octubre
Trust fue reemplazada
quien se convirtió en el primero de una
minoría étnica en ocupar el cargo de
Primer Ministro de Reino Unido y llegó
al número 10 de Down Street con la
promesa de restaurar la confianza en el
gobierno
vamos a Perú Durante los últimos seis
años el país ha tenido seis presidentes
cuatro de los cuales No han terminado su
periodo de gobernanza El último de ellos
fue Pedro Castillo el exmandatario fue
destituido por el mismo congreso que
intentó disolver y su salida provocó un
estallido social que ha dejado varios
Muertos Cómo llegó Perú hasta aquí nos
los cuenta nuestro corresponsal en Lima
Francisco Zacarías
el 7 de diciembre Pedro Castillo
disolvió El Congreso de Perú para evitar
un tercer proceso en pitchmen o vacancia
presidencial impulsado por el parlamento
cuando este ni siquiera contaba con 87
votos necesarios para destituirlo qué
fue lo que ocurrió al ex mandatario le
dijeron que muchos congresistas votarían
por la vacancia luego de escuchar las
acusaciones de dos testigos quienes
señalaron que Pedro Castillo no solo
habría consentido el robo sino también
habría recibido parte de los sobornos el
miedo a perder el poder empujó el ex
gobernante a quebrar el orden
constitucional el congreso con 101 votos
lo destituyó Castillo intentó fugar pero
fue detenido y días después la justicia
le impuso 18 meses de prisión preventiva
por los delitos de rebelión conspiración
y abuso de autoridad la inestabilidad de
Perú no es de ahora se remonta a 2016 y
junto con Pedro Pablo kuczynski Martín
vizcarra y Manuel Merino Pedro Castillo
es el cuarto presidente que no termina
su gobierno en los últimos seis años la
corrupción salpica a las a la clase
política que origina conflictos que
debilitan a la democracia luego de la
destitución de Pedro Castillo las
protestas se encendieron en Perú pero no
todo se movilizan en defensa del ex
gobernante son peruanos que se sienten
cansados por el sistema neoliberal que
desde hace más de 30 años impone la
derecha y los grupos económicos la
población exige cambios pero el
descontento popular también es
aprovechado por radicales e instigadores
que impulsan el vandalismo con toma de
algunos aeropuertos bloqueo de
carreteras y saqueos la presidenta Dina
boluarte ordenó el estado de emergencia
nacional hasta el momento hay varios
peruanos muertos por las protestas la
mandataria anunció el adelanto de
elecciones y también pidió una tregua
logrará Dina boluarte enrumbar al Perú
solo el tiempo lo dirá
pasamos a Irán que vivió en 2022
históricas protestas que comenzaron como
un rechazo a la muerte bajo custodia de
la joven Max a mini quien había sido
detenida acusada de no llevar
correctamente el velo islámico sin
embargo esas manifestaciones se
convirtieron en un movimiento de
descontento contra una histórica
represión que ha llevado a cabo el
gobierno iraní desde Terán nuestra
corresponsal Catalina Gómez Ángel nos
hace un repaso de lo sucedido
en la medida que van pasando los años
son cada vez más frecuentes las
protestas en contra de la República
islámica de Irán la última gran protesta
había sucedido en el 2019 Pero entonces
había sido más la parte de las
periferias de las ciudades el sector
económico que había salido a protestar
de ahí la gran sorpresa tal vez de las
instituciones del sistema de la
República islámica de ver cómo
especialmente las mujeres y aquel sector
de la población joven salió a protestar
después de la muerte de esa joven de 22
años Max examiní después de haber sido
capturada por la policía de la moral y
llevada a una comisaría y murió
rápidamente después de eso Por lo cual
muchas personas en Irán la gran mayoría
de las personas que están en la calle
piensan que esta mujer Murió como
consecuencia de abusos de esta policía
de la moral que lleva deteniendo durante
meses y durante años pero especialmente
desde los meses de Julio cuando se
reactivó esa presión contra las mujeres
especialmente por ese vestir de las de
ellas en las calles estas protestas
continúan hasta el día de hoy la
represión es inmensa al menos 500
personas según organizaciones de
derechos humanos han muerto 18.000
especialmente jóvenes están en las
prisiones y se habla cada vez más de
abusos contra especialmente mujeres en
estas prisiones sin embargo ellos han
intentado
amedrentar a la población con estas dos
ejecuciones que llevan hasta el momento
pero la población sigue protestando y
pidiendo que no se dé más este tipo de
sentencias
la saga Twitter y la más fue uno de los
temas que encabezó los titulares de
noticias durante 2022 desde que
manifestó su intención de comprar la
compañía y hasta el día de hoy las
decisiones del multimillonario sobre la
red social siguen causando controversia
por ejemplo la suspensión de cuentas a
varios periodistas aún cuando se
autodenomina como un defensor de la
libertad de expresión a continuación un
resumen de lo que ha sucedido en los
últimos meses entre El Magnate y la
plataforma
todo empezó como un comentario
Aparentemente jocoso en 2017 elon musk
preguntó cuánto costaba Twitter cuando
alguien le sugirió que comprara la
plataforma cinco años más tarde se
convirtió en su dueño Pero para llegar a
ello atravesó una serie de calamidades
Después de llegar a ser el accionista
individual con mayor participación de la
red social quiso dar un paso más
ambicioso Después de varios días de
pensar en esto He decidido que quiero
adquirir la empresa y convertirla en
privada su oferta 44 mil millones de
dólares por toda la compañía después de
que Twitter aceptara
mosc suspendió el trato y luego dijo que
se retiraba del todo alegando que la
compañía no ofrecía información adecuada
sobre la cantidad de cuentas falsas que
había en su plataforma finalmente
revivió su intención de seguir adelante
con la compra y así evitar el juicio con
el que Twitter quería obligarlo a
completar la transacción el acuerdo se
cerró en Octubre y entre las primeras
medidas
mosc despidió a miles de personas
Empezando por los altos ejecutivos de la
empresa
era el inicio de una serie de decisiones
que pusieron al Magnate en el ojo del
huracán Como por ejemplo restaurar la
cuenta del expresidente Donald Trump que
había sido acusado de incitar a la
violencia a través de sus redes sociales
traer de vuelta al ex mandatario hacía
parte de su idea de luchar contra la
restricción del discurso y convertir a
la plataforma en un espacio que
garantizara la libertad de expresión sin
embargo de manera contradictoria un par
de semanas después suspendió la cuenta
de varios periodistas del New York Times
CNN y el Washington post se les acusaba
de violar la nueva política de
privacidad por compartir información del
paradero en tiempo real del Jet privado
de mosc y la medida le acarreó críticas
internacionales y amenazas de sanciones
después de unos turbulentos meses de su
reinado
mosc preguntó a sus seguidores si
consideraban que debía apartarse como
jefe de Twitter un 57% de los votantes
respondió que sí esto significa que la
compañía no de sufrir cambios en el
corto plazo manteniendo a los usuarios a
la expectativa
y cerramos con algunas de las mejores
imágenes que nos dejó este 2022
provenientes del espacio se trata de las
fotografías captadas por el telescopio
espacial James webb el observatorio
orbital más grande y poderoso jamás
lanzado y que ha permitido a los
científicos mirar Más allá de lo que ya
hemos visto y con mayor Claridad por
ejemplo miles de galaxias distantes y
brillantes nebulosas
de esta manera despedimos esta edición
especial de noticias en France 24
Gracias por acompañarnos continúen con
toda nuestra programación Feliz año
nuevo
[Música]